The error that we just saw happening in the quiz is called the global truncation error or GTE if you will.
This error stems from using a finite step size.
If you would be using an infinitely small step size, you could theoretically achieve zero error.
That's part of the truncation using a finite step size and as we saw,
this global truncation error depends approximately linearly on the step size.
It's more or less some constant times h for the forward Euler's method.
This is different for other methods and beware this constant depends on the simulation time.
If you look at the global truncation error at this point, it maybe smaller
if you take at some further orbital periods, this truncation error may explode.
Beware of that this constant is not a constant when it comes to changing the time.
When there's a global truncation error, there's of course a local truncation error.
That's the error that we're making in every step.
See this supplementary material for the local truncation error if you're interested.